You know increasingly we're using
automated technology in ways that kind
of support humans and what they're doing
rather than just having algorithms work
on their own because they're not smart
enough to do that yet or deal with
unexpected situations. So we're
interacting more and more with these
systems and so you need an interface
that makes sense for a human to interact
with. And so a lot of these systems have an interface that is personified and
that will talk to you.
The effect that I'm so interested in the psychological effect of us treating
these systems like social actors is
actually - we achieved that in the 60s.
Like in the 60s we had this chatbot
called Eliza that Joseph Weizenbaum
made. It's a really famous example
of a really simple chatbot all it did
was answer everything with a question
like a psychoanalyst would. So if you're
like "oh, I don't like my mom" it would be
like "why don't you like your mom." And
people would just open up and tell it
all sorts of things, even though it was
very primitive and how it behaved. So
it's useful that we will engage with
these systems on a social level because
it's engaging for people and you can get
people to actually use the systems more.
But I do wonder whether there's any
effect on our behavior. On our long-term
behavioral development. It really gets
interesting when we start talking about kids. You have these systems like Siri, and Alexa that kids are interacting with and
if these systems are simulating lifelike
behavior or a real conversation then
that could actually influence kids'
behavioral development and the way that
they start to converse with other people.
There's some examples of this just
anecdotally that we have so far like
there was an article in New York Times
a few years ago about this kid, this autistic
boy who developed a relationship with
Siri. And the mom was like "this is the best thing ever. Siri is infinitely patient
will answer all of his questions. Also
the voice recognition
is so shitty that he had to learn to
articulate his words really well and it's
made him a better communicator with
other people because of Siri." But then on
the other hand you have stories like
this one guy wrote an article a few
months ago about how Alexa was turning
his kids into assholes because she
doesn't require any please or thank you
or any of the standard politeness that
you want your kids to learn in
conversing with others. So you know I
think it is an interesting question that
the more we're able to simulate like a
real conversation with these systems the
more that might get muddled in our
subconscious in some way.
One of the things that I think is
really necessary is that we need to
study more what impact this can have on
our behavior. So we definitely need to be
studying these interactions and studying
the effects of these interactions.
It's a similar question to violent
video games or pornography. These
are questions that have come up again
and again but i think that these systems
bring them to a new more visceral level
in our psychology. So we need more
research and then depending on what the
answer to that specific question is we
might need to think about design and use
and maybe even policy for regulating
these agents. Part of the problem is also
that this is such an
interdisciplinary problem. All of the
questions that are coming up are so
interdisciplinary you need technologists
you need policymakers you need users you
need researchers who understand
psychology, who understand technology who
understand sociology like all of this is
coming together. And you need
people talking to each other. I would
really like us to in the next few years to
lean into the positive effects of the
technology and develop structures the
way that we have in other fields like
medicine to ensure that we're using the
technology and responsible ethical way.